皆さんこんにちは 麻生菜穂美と申します
若柳梅京という名前で日本舞踊をやっています
この仙台市から少し南に行った
白石市に住んでいます
今踊ってくれた子供達は その白石市で
無料の日本舞踊講座
月２回だけお稽古している子供達
踊ってくれた曲は『藤娘』という
約200年前に作られた長唄の名曲で
舞踊としても大変人気のある曲です
今日は皆さんに ちょっと触りだけご覧頂きました
皆さん 日本舞踊というと
すごく難しいというイメージがありませんか？
はい すごく難しいんです 実は
本当に難しい
５歳６歳から始めて
50 60でもまだまだという世界
でも私も55歳になりますが 実は私は
ずっとこの世界にいたわけではないんです
10年ちょっと前 日本舞踊を本格的に再開する前は
小学校のとき５〜６年だけやって
日本舞踊をやめてしまっていたんです
私の家は 400年以上続く禅宗のお寺です
祖父は政治家でもありました
いつも周囲から見られているというプレッシャー
そして古いもの 窮屈なものから逃げ出したい
というその一心で日本舞踊をやめ
中学からはバンド活動に精を出しました
そして新しいもの 未知なるものに惹かれて
アメリカへ留学することにしたのです
40年前から アメリカのハイスクールは
とても華やかでした
みんなファッショナブルです
ちょっと私 冬なのに浴衣を着ていて
おかしいんですけれども
はい それで私はといえば
アジアから来たただのチビ
格好もダサいです 英語もしゃべれません
誰も相手にしてくれませんでした
ところがある日 文化祭のようなものがあって
勇気を振り絞って 日本から持っていった振袖を
なんとかかんとか一人で着て
そして日本舞踊 小さい頃習っていた日本舞踊を
ちょっとやってみたんです 一曲
そうしたら 次の日からたくさんの生徒が
次から次へと私に話しかけてくるのです
「ねえ 君 日本から来たんだって？
日本てどんな国？」
「ねえ 君 日本人て着物着て刀差してるんでしょ
なんで君ジーパンはいてるの」
「富士山て何フィートですか？」
「天皇陛下ってどんな人？」
「君 空手できますか？」
もう次から次へと質問攻めです
今のように携帯やインターネットはありません
もう持っていた辞書とわずかな本を
一生懸命調べて
なんとかかんとか片言の英語で説明しました
そしてたくさんのお友達ができました
最初は なぜ急に友達ができるようになったのか
よくわかりませんでした
でも後で気がついたんです
ああ この子は自分の国を そして自分の国の
古いものを大切に思っている子なんだなと思って
私を尊敬してくれたんだということが
尊敬といっても当時の高校生です
単に踊りを見て びっくりしたとか すごいなと
思ってくれただけだったかもしれません
それでも 尊敬する人と喧嘩をしようと思う人は
どこにもいませんよね
みんな仲良くなりたいと思います
そのことに気づかされたのです
大学卒業後は いくつかの国際企業を経て
私はオリンピックに携わることになりました
98年の長野冬季オリンピック
そしてその前年の97年
私は日本側とのリエゾン 調整役として
国際オリンピック委員会(IOC)の本部へ
行くことになりました
当時のサマランチ会長ですね
スイス ローザンヌのIOCではさまざまな人と
お話しすることができました
なかでも IOC委員という
世界に100人しかいない人達
その方の多くは貴族や皇族だったりします
そんな人が私を見るとこう話しかけてくるのです
「ねえ 菜穂美 今度茶の湯を
見せてくれない？」とか
「今度日本に帰ったら盆栽の本を
買ってきてくれない？」とか言うんです
盆栽ですよ 皆さん あの100年かかって
小さな松を作り上げるという
日本でも今 ほんの一部の人しか
やってらっしゃらない趣味だと思いますが
それまで仕事一筋 日本文化から
すっかり離れていた私は またびっくりしました
そしてまた日本人であることに
気づかされたのです
それからは 時間を見ては 日本料理をふるまったり
女性職員に折り紙の折り方を教えたりして
とても喜ばれました
そして たくさんの友達ができました
そんな私が 2002年 病気をして
この宮城県に戻ってきました
そして 自然に文化の世界に入ったのです
今は 日本舞踊を通じて
子供達に日本文化を伝えること
そして日本文化を通じて 国際交流を深めることを
ライフワークとしています
白石市には能楽堂があります
お能という日本で最も古い
芸能をする 専用の舞台のある建物です
そこに 白石市では小学校４年生になると 全員
男の子も女の子もクラスごとにやってきて
私の授業を受けることになっています
まず なぜ学校でなくてこの能楽堂に来て
授業を受けなければならないかという話を
少しアメリカでのエピソードも交えてお話します
それからこのように舞台に上がって
もちろん白足袋を履きますよ
そしてきちっと正座をして
お辞儀をするところから 日本舞踊の基礎
一曲踊れるようになるところまでやります
とても厳しいので
みんなヒーヒー言ってやっていますが
最後は 「わー楽しかった」と
言ってくれるのが救いです
今の子供達は 欧米の子供達と
まったく同じ生活をしています
彼らにとって 日本文化は異文化です
日舞や茶道など 見たことも
やったこともありません
でも私は子供達に言います
「君達は大人になったとき
外国に行くかもしれないね
外国に行かなくても 日本にたくさんの外国の人が
住むようになるかもしれない
そしたら一緒に仕事をする人や
もしかすると 君達の奥さんや旦那さんも
外国の人になるかもしれないね
そしたらかならず聞かれますよ
『君 何か私に日本のこと教えてください』
『君 何かやったことがありますか？
何かできますか？』って
どうする？」子供達は一様に困った顔をします
私は何でもいいから 一つ日本のことを
やってごらんと言います
和太鼓でも書道でも 何でもいいと
「でも俺さ サッカーやスイミングしか
興味がねえし」と言う子もいます
そんな子にも言います
「今日 みんなすごいことをやるんだよ
この能舞台に上がって 日本舞踊をやるんだよ」
「だから将来 外国の人とお話しを
するようになったら胸を張って
『僕ね 小学校４年生のときに能舞台に上がって
日本舞踊をやったことがあるよ』と
言ってごらん」と
「やったことがあるでいいんだよ
そしたらね 外国の人はきっと
『へー 君そんなことやったことがあるの
すごいね』と言って
君達を尊敬してくれるでしょう」
「尊敬する人と喧嘩をしようと思う人は
どこにもいないよね
だから みんな仲良くなれるんだよ」と言います
はい それからこう続けます
「今日みんながやる日本舞踊
『立って 座って 回って 手を上げて』
とやります」
「体操と同じだね でも日本舞踊と体操には
決定的に違うことが一つだけあります
何だろう？
それは心だよ」と言います
日本には美しい４つの季節があります
春 夏 秋 冬 きっちり３か月ずつ分かれています
最近は温暖化の影響でちょっと夏が長いですか
でも日本人は昔からその美しい４つの季節を
大事に慈しんできました
日本文化にはその自然を慈しむ心 愛でる心
そして人を思いやる気持ちが流れています
お能や歌舞伎 和歌や俳句
そして日本料理にいたるまで
すべての日本文化にその心が流れていると
言っても過言ではありません
ちょっと具体的な話をしましょう
今日 私は秋なので紅葉の着物を着てきました
ちょっと派手で恥ずかしいんですけれども
はい 日本の季節を最も敏感に取り入れているのが
この和服 着物です
私たちは冬になると雪景色の着物を着たりします
そして春になるとこんな桜の模様の着物や
若草色の着物を着たりします
夏になると 人から見ても涼しく見えるように
白や水色の着物
そして川の流れや夏の絵が描いてあるような
着物を着たりします
私は子供達に聞きます
「君達は春になったからって『お母さんそろそろ
桜のＴシャツ着たいから買って』とか
『お母さん 俺 そろそろ紅葉のトレーナー着たいな』とか言わないでしょう？」と
男の子は一年中 ナイキ プーマ アディダスです
一年中ですよね
では着物を着て 日本文化だけ
やっていればいいのでしょうか
いいえ 違いますよね
先ほど踊ってくれた子供達の講座
こちらの休憩時間に私は
簡単な英会話を取り入れています
自分の国の文化を知った上で
コミュニケーション能力もなければなりません
私はこの地元から 宮城県から
互いの文化を理解し合える本当の 真の国際人が
たくさん出てくれることを心から願っています
東日本大震災のときに生まれた
共に助け合う連帯の精神 そして人を思いやる心
私達が取った行動は 世界中から称賛されました
その姿を保ちつつ 自分の国の文化を理解し
誇りを持ち さらに多様性を認め合うことで
私達はもっともっと尊敬されるように
なるのではないでしょうか
皆さんもぜひ 日本文化を一つやってみませんか
これからのグローバル社会
きっとお役に立つことと私は信じています
私もこれから 日本舞踊を通じて
季節を愛でる心 そして人を思いやる
気持ちを持った美しい日本文化を
子供達に そして世界中に
伝えていけたらと思っています
文化の力で平和な世界が実現できますように
ありがとうございました